see you guys again how are you alright
well we are here recognizing your
incredible work again how has this award
season felt for you it's been non-stop
first of all there's so many award
ceremonies you love it why do you love
it coolerado and filmmaker didn't appeal
gonnigan sec totally from the chill
coquí's island
you had to charge a pony combined in
teenagers and now to have your film up
against Todd Phillips film Joker for
Best Picture I mean that must feel
surreal wouldn't mean to wake up to six
Oscar nominations anymore would engage
dominica Golden Glove more Critics
Choice not an O Lord Simon two kills
Connor knows katana as a turn out to get
Hermann Gunkel a modern community at sea
no letter for me and also all Korean
industry
he'll go nearly catch a key Rajan and
the Kim ego - yes I'm a demon yamato-kun
eternity Raja Seneca don't they it will
go in editor but we don't make films for
that but was it when it happens it's
great and this might not be the last
time we see parasite we've heard that it
might be a series on HBO now you're
working with Adam McKay on it what can
we expect good scenario suitable tiger
so Jung in on your wisest choice home
young hey Shannon Kenai you might hear
some car in the manner I do Theresa sir
cougar little Adam McKay you I am I
Kapila reso you also she can't sorry I'm
Adam and didn't the Kim
even when I was writing the script I had
all these ideas that I couldn't convey
all these hidden things that could
happen in this story so I want to create
like a six hour film and give all those
ideas to Adam McKay
that's incredible sell a movie extended
movie we're here for it we want to see
it projects are so thought-provoking
parasite a snowpiercer what is the next
idea that you want to tackle do you have
your next big one percolating already to
get young doujin by wind and their
chicken when they're talking monkey that
it's in the works
I would like to explain it all to you
now but please wait a little you're
teasing us are all eyes on you
congratulations on everything yeah thank
you guys very very much
[Music]